what is gold star who lived who died and
will the BAU survive next season this is
the ending of Criminal Minds evolution
season one explained
when Criminal Minds Evolution begins
agent Dave Rossi is in a hotel room
which she has apparently been living in
for months the walls are covered in
crime scene photographs as he pours
himself into his work instead of coming
to terms with his grief over the death
of his wife Crystal he hasn't been going
into the office and Emily Prentiss is
covering for him with the people who
work above her as Rossi tracks down
zacarius he's kidnapped by the team's
Prime Suspect Elias Voigt while trapped
in a shipping container underground
Rossi experiences a hallucination in
which Crystal convinces him to keep
living when he wants to give up Rossi's
Evolution over the course of the season
is important for his growth and
acceptance of his life cracking the
Nationwide murderer ring gives him
something to work toward thanks to the
work he puts in he can accept his wife's
words and return to the world of the
living instead of wishing to be with the
dead as the series moves into the next
season it's likely fans will see an even
more determined Rossi not the sad
individual his colleagues came to know
at the start of the season
at the end of season 15 of Criminal
Minds Penelope leaves the BAU to take on
a new adventure when audiences are
reintroduced to her in evolution she's
taking time for herself by meditating
hosting baking parties and being mindful
of the content she consumes in other
words she's steering clear of anything
that could remind her of her old job
when JJ and Luke pull her back in
because of where a suspect is meeting
victims Penelope breaks the boundary
she's set for herself she throws herself
back into a job she willingly left for
greener pastures after a single request
and an informant that appeals to her
curiosity by the end of the season she's
romantically interested in a witness for
a federal investigation though they go
their separate ways due to a lack of
trust penalty makes sure to tell him and
the audience that maintaining her
professional and personal boundaries is
something she needs to continue to work
on if she's going to return to the BAU
in a more permanent capacity while
investigating sakarius Tara makes the
difficult decision to ask to Rio up in
an old case the tricky part of this case
is it made her partner Rebecca's career
reopening and potentially changing the
outcome could heavily impact Rebecca
especially since she's moved up in the
ranks in the Department of Justice while
they are happy and are even considering
moving in together what they've built is
immediately fractured by Tara's request
she doesn't talk to Rebecca first and
though Rebecca asks her not to push it
Tara does by the end of the season Tara
wants to make amends but Rebecca is
offered a job in Sacramento and decides
to take it Tara isn't upfront about her
intentions regarding the case and tries
to remedy the situation only for Rebecca
to shut down and make the decision to
cut off contact I have never not been on
your side
[Music]
you couldn't be honest with me about
what you needed
with their relationship left the way it
is it's unlikely we'll see the two back
together when the next season starts
however with the revelation of gold star
there's a significant chance that
Rebecca will be back despite her new job
while the BAU is trying to hunt down
zacarius they also deal with significant
pushback from the federal government the
director is concerned with how
Apprentice is utilizing resources and
there is a significant interest in
combining the BAU with the domestic
terrorism unit after a bit of back and
forth deputy director Doug Bailey is
sent to communicate with Elias in the
final episode he goes into the house
wearing a bulletproof vest and is killed
by a single shot to the Head Elias
doesn't hesitate when he takes the
deputy director's life if you can't do
this just tell us with so many close
calls throughout the season it wouldn't
be realistic for every team member to
make it out alive considering how brutal
the investigation becomes but for bayley
to draw the Short Straw is a surprise he
thinks he's safe because Elias knows
about Goldstar he goes into the house
and the possibility of Elias killing him
doesn't appear to cross his mind Bailey
thinks he knows Elias because of their
shared knowledge and he thinks he can
use it to his advantage in this case
he's wrong dead wrong
as audiences watch JJ help the team they
also see some of her personal life her
oldest son Henry seems to have a
girlfriend she's working a lot and her
husband will has some concerning test
results JJ and Will's marriage seems
strong but it's clear that will is
struggling with the idea of being sick
while additional tests are coming back
clear he inexplicably still has an
elevated white blood cell count which
could mean there is something else
hiding in his body despite his doctor
giving him the all clear in addition to
dealing with that will and JJ run back
into the same issue that's come up time
and time again in their relationship
work life balance will has always
wrestled with JJ's hours and how often
she has to be gone will goes with her to
Seattle as the team Corners Elias and
hints at wanting to continue working
with her in this capacity could their
work-life balance issue be remedied if
they start working together again this
isn't a new Dynamic to their
relationship but their method for
handling it has matured particularly on
Will's side he quit his job when they
first got together and struggled to
adapt to his new life this time around
his more understanding of JJ's work and
seems willing to adapt to the schedule
this season audiences are introduced to
Tyler a vigilante who works to
infiltrate the sicarious ring Because he
believes the ringleader is responsible
for his sister's death he's the
informant who sends the locations of the
kill kids and even agrees to be a
witness in the federal investigation
because of what he knows about the crime
ring so where does capturing Elias leave
Tyler it looks like he'll survive his
gunshot wound so the only matter is
whether or not the government will need
Tyler's testimony when they pursue the
case against Elias if Elias is
prosecuted it's likely that Tyler will
pop up a time or two in the next season
but nothing is set in stone just yet the
question is while taking on the Persona
of the killer did Tyler lose himself
along the way Rossi found his way out
but Tyler is only moving on to the next
chapter of the screen
when Elias tries to kill his wife
Bridget he fails because his gun's
magazine is empty after this incident
Bridget is in disbelief over the events
of the past few days and confused about
who she married the current plan is for
her and her daughters to enter witness
protection however it's unlikely that's
the last time audiences will see Elias's
family the serial killers network is
large chances are there's a plan in
place in case he's captured and it won't
be long before his followers hear about
his arrest on the news this plan could
include locating his family and tying up
Loose Ends Elias is incredibly talented
when it comes to breaking into networks
and learning things that are typically
locked behind several layers of
encryption if he ever gets his hand on a
phone or computer he could easily figure
out where his family is depending on
what the federal government decides to
do he could be out of jail and tracking
them down as early as the first episode
of the next season either way witness
protection isn't going to keep his
family safe if Elias or his associates
want to find them they will the only
question is what will happen when they
do over the course of the Season
princess's job is repeatedly threatened
from deputy director Bailey using her
every action as ammunition against her
to the attorney General trying to blame
Prentice for Bailey's death there isn't
a time when Prentice isn't worried about
her job how could this change with the
new season after Bailey's funeral
Prentice shares what she knows about
gold star with the rest of the team
while it isn't much it's enough to
interest everyone meaning that they
could become a thorn in the department
of Justice's side as they search for
answers depending on what actions they
take Apprentice could be an even more
hot water if Prentiss loses her job the
entire BAU could fall apart bayley tries
to stick up for her in the end but with
him gone and her team asking questions
it's only a matter of time before
audiences see a huge shift within the
team firing Prentiss would give the
higher Powers the perfect excuse to fold
the BAU into domestic terrorism since
the ship wouldn't have a captain
apprentice and the team are already on
thin ice and pushing for more
information about the secret gold star
issue could result in massive
repercussions their deaths would be
chalked up to acceptable if not
necessary losses if the BAU is combined
with domestic terrorism it's safe to say
that not everyone's job will survive the
merge Rossi would be forced into
retirement and the team would likely all
be stationed in different parts of the
country without the BAU the next season
of Criminal Minds Evolution could take a
drastic turn audiences could see the
team fighting to be put back together
Prentiss taking an early retirement or
transitioning into a random position
within the federal government and Rossi
falling back into a depression without
work to keep his mind occupied it could
also result in lots of work behind
closed doors it's unlikely that the team
is going to let Goldstar go anytime soon
so even if they aren't together the
chances are high that they will continue
trying to find the truth
well the BAU spends most of the Season
trying to catch zacarius and shut down
his crime ring they also try to prove
their Worth to the powers above them
from the first episode deputy director
Bailey is trying to cut funding remove
Apprentice from her position and
dismantle the BAU this is only
reinforced as the season moves along
especially when they try to arrest a
senator's son and reopen a closed case
though Prentiss wants to arrest the
Senator's son especially after he's
found holding someone in their car at
gunpoint the people above her think
otherwise she should have control over
her jurisdiction and her agents but
that's taken away from her because of
who it involves the politics of it all
really impacts the team's ability to
work quickly against zacarius especially
with other cases to handle as well this
season shows just how ineffective the
team can be when they aren't given what
they need hopefully that changes in the
next season
when Elias speaks to deputy director
Bailey on the phone he mentions that he
knows Bailey likes getting gold stars
this is a coded message referencing
something called gold star that Bailey
Rebecca and attorney general Louise
Davis discuss it's clearly something
going on within the Department of
Justice that Elias knows about and his
knowledge may have influenced his
decision to kill bayley the nature of
gold star isn't revealed but there are
several Clues as to what it could be
based on Bailey's discomfort with the
BAU moving to arrest a sitting senator's
son it could have something to do with
well-known members of the United States
government when this initially happens
in the fifth episode you don't think
much of it but combined with the
knowledge that the Department of Justice
is hiding something it looks a bit more
suspicious when Tara asks Rebecca about
the phrase in the final episode all
Rebecca is willing to give up is all I
can say is there are issues within the
doj with Elias in custody and only
willing to speak to the attorney general
there's a significant chance that the
next season will see the BAU not just
trying to save their department but
trying to figure out what gold star is
and why Elias knows about it after all a
secret between a serial killer and the
federal government is never a good thing
foreign